[Musique]
les parents que l'on surnomme
hélicoptères se sont investis dans la
vie de leurs enfants ils ont beaucoup
fait parler d'eux depuis quelques années
ses parents souvent ultra protecteur
exige le meilleur pour leur petit en
chine des parents continuent de
s'investir dans la vie de leurs enfants
jusqu'à un âge avancé que ce soit dans
leur vie académique ou amoureuse par
exemple il n'est plus rare de voir des
parents suivre à la trace leurs enfants
lors de leur rentrée universitaire des
universités chinoises ont d'ailleurs
bien saisi cette anxiété de séparation
et permettent aux parents de camper dans
le gymnase de l'établissement durant
quelques jours des producteurs de
télévision aussi flairé la fibre
protectrice de ses parents la
téléréalité chinese d'été ou surf sur
cette tendance en nombre depuis l'hiver
cette émission permet aux parents de
choisir une épouse potentielle pour
leurs garçons et jeunes femmes qui
participent à l'émission passe de
véritables entrevue d'embauché pour
mériter l'accord de maman et papa la
politique de l'enfant unique qui fut en
vigueur durant 35 ans a certainement
créé des générations de parents qui ont
misé beaucoup sur leur précieux et seul
enfant
[Musique]